from a real hospital that's said to be
haunted to a clever Twist on an age-old
vampire rule Renfield has a whole slew
of tiny details that could easily be
overlooked here's what you might have
missed
right from the jump Renfield firmly
establishes in the most tongue-in-cheek
way possible that it's technically a
sequel to the 1931 monster movie
starring Bella Lugosi in the first five
minutes of Renfield a backstory
revealing scene establishes all of this
in a playful meta manner the movie takes
a sequence from the original Dracula and
digitally adds the faces of Nicholas
Holt and Nicholas Cage onto the actors
bodies in this sequence from the 1931
film Renfield meets Dracula for the
first time at a castle however the film
twists the scene by having Holt deliver
renfield's lines then there's cage who
has Dracula literally takes the words
right out of lugosi's mouth
I am Dracula
Renfield production designer Alec
Hammond alluded to the scene while
speaking to joblo he told the outlet
we're actually using some direct
references to the original Universal
horror movie we definitely use some of
those frames so even if you'd never seen
the 1931 Dracula movie if you've never
seen Bella Lugosi you will understand
these days one of the easiest punch
lines is ska a horn-driven style of
music that originated in Jamaica in
Renfield an entire running gag is
devoted to poking fun of Ska music and
its fans one way the film does this is
through a costuming detail that's easy
to miss early on in the movie there's a
scene where a woman who's attending a
support group describes her abusive drug
dealing boyfriend despite all the
Terrible Things he's done however the
woman claims that the worst thing about
him is the fact that he's a ska fan the
very next scene shows a group of three
guys in a warehouse that's filled with
cocaine one of the guys is wearing a
shirt that says NYC ska by connecting
the dots viewers can draw the conclusion
that the T-shirt wearing guy is probably
the woman's boyfriend so since Renfield
is looking for victims who deserve to
have their blood sucked he naturally
goes after the skull loving knuckleheads
aquafina's character in Renfield is
named Rebecca Quincy Quincy is a police
officer with a big heart and a dark past
so she shares a common bond with
Renfield particularly in their mission
to take on the Lobo crime family
ultimately Quincy's friendship with
Renfield helps him see the error of his
ways in his dealings with Dracula I work
for Dracula Count Dracula however a
little Easter egg that only the most
hardcore Dracula fans might get is that
the name Quincy is actually used in Bram
Stoker's original 1897 novel In the book
there is a character named Quincy Morris
the names aren't the only similarity
however as these two characters serve
similar narrative functions in their
respective tales in Bram Stoker's
Dracula Quincy Morris helps Jonathan
Harker defeat the vampire lord and he's
also a character who went on to appear
in multiple adaptations of the tale
renfield's Rebecca Quincy is a new Twist
on the same character though she still
helps to defeat renfield's toxic boss
just as the character did in earlier
versions of the story so in more ways
than just her name the Rebecca Quincy
character is clearly part of a Dracula
lineage
since the state of Louisiana has
embraced significant tax incentives for
production companies New Orleans has
become a popular destination for
filmmakers in recent decades some of the
films that have been shot in the city
include bad moms American Ultra 12 Years
a Slave both 21 Jump Street films the
skeleton key and Cage's Bad Lieutenant
Port of Call New Orleans additionally TV
shows like True Detective and Treme have
also shot entire Seasons In The Big Easy
for Renfield however capturing the vibe
of the city was just as important as the
tax deductions by using iconic New
Orleans locations like mulat's
restaurant and Charity Hospital for
major set pieces Renfield is infused
with the spirit of New Orleans at the
film's premiere Nicholas Cage told
nola.com this is a city that does have
an X Factor you don't know how to define
it it's just in the air it's in the
feelings it's in the mood you can have a
Charming time and then in a split second
you could really be a a little bit
unnerved and you don't know exactly why
when Renfield first brings the emaciated
Dracula to New Orleans he finds an
abandoned building in which to take
shelter and build a new layer later in
the movie It's revealed that Renfield
and Dracula are actually staying at the
abandoned old Charity Hospital in real
life the hospital exists and is very
much deserted you can find the Erie
Hospital in downtown New Orleans where
it sticks out like a sore thumb but
aside from just being creepy looking
Charity Hospital also has a dark
potentially haunted history thus making
it the perfect Locale for vampires to
hold up the Charity Hospital in New
Orleans has been abandoned since it
suffered severe damage from Hurricane
Katrina in 2005. years back a photo of
lights shining from the windows of the
hospital went viral this had some locals
and online theorists convinced that
there were Spirits present while no one
can be certain whether ghosts exist in
the building this mystery at least had a
rational solution an investigation LED
police to discover that the source was a
pile of 2 by fours wrapped in lights
however no further explanations were
given the potential of the supernatural
remains very much on the table however
for those who choose to believe it
while Renfield gets most of the
nitty-gritty of its setting right there
is one New Orleans detail that the movie
does not portray with accuracy this
detail concerns the police officers in
New Orleans who play a surprisingly
large role in the film in addition to
centering its B plot around Rebecca
Quincy the main thrust of renfield's
narrative involves a brewing conflict
between the cops and the Lobo crime
family in the film The Police wear
Badges and uniforms that all say the
same thing pdno this abbreviation which
is apparently short for Police
Department of New Orleans can even be
found on the police cars in reality
however this is not what the New Orleans
Police Department is called the nopd is
the official name for the New Orleans
Police Department perhaps the City of
New Orleans didn't want to see the bulk
of its police force portrayed as
incompetent or maybe it had something to
do with the gruesome end so many of the
cops meet in the film regardless this
change is only really noticeable to
anyone who who has spent significant
time in New Orleans
the filmmakers behind Renfield didn't
just draw upon Bram Stoker and his
original novels direct adaptations when
coming up with its vampire themed
touchstones the notion that vampires
must be invited in order to enter a home
has become a familiar vampire cliche for
instance however Renfield subverts this
in a clever way
in the world of the film Vampires even
ones as powerful as Lord Dracula still
need to be invited in to enter a
building this is emphasized when the
support group organizer Mark cheerfully
invites the dark lord into a meeting
near the end of the film okay obviously
we're dealing with a little bit more
than just narcissism here but in a small
gag before this moment Renfield turns
the Trope on its head after Renfield
goes off on his own Dracula comes
looking for him when he gets to
renfield's apartment Dracula is allowed
to come in and wait for Renfield to get
home this is all due to the fact that
Renfield has a welcome mat outside that
literally invites people in the movie
uses this as a clever ploy to get
Dracula into renfield's apartment
needless to say it's also a pretty funny
moment as Renfield spends more time with
Rebecca and the members of his support
group he begins to create a life and
identity outside of his relationship
with Dracula I need to get out of a
toxic relationship taking steps to
become his own person Renfield gets his
own apartment which he decorates with a
slew of motivational posters while many
of these posters are fairly generic
often with large printed words and
phrases of inspiration next to pictures
of majestic animals one in particular
stands out however this poster also
receives very little attention blink and
you might miss how on a different wall
in renfield's colorful apartment there
is a lone motivational poster that reads
I am enough I have enough this phrase is
repeated throughout the movie and is
first pass to Renfield in his support
group for people with dependent
relationships it can be assumed perhaps
that this is where he picked up the
poster in the first place this
affirmation ultimately helps Renfield
move Beyond his co-dependent
relationship with Dracula the
codependency is toxic but there's a
level of Love there when he finally gets
the upper hand he repeats the phrase
while beating his master to a bloody
pulp
in the world of Renfield people are
depicted as something akin to walking
sacks of blood waiting to be popped like
a pimple some viewers will love the
violence the film offers others will
likely roll their eyes at the excess but
at the very end of the movie viewers are
perhaps more likely to at least
understand the inspiration behind the
film's outrageous takes on violence and
Gore when Teddy Lobo is killed by
Renfield there is a moment that Echoes
the Mortal Kombat games The Scene goes
into full x-ray mode inside Teddy's body
allowing viewers to see his bones
breaking this is reminiscent of the
X-ray moves in modern Mortal Kombat
games in fact this near direct homage to
the fighting franchise is a moment that
might make some viewers consider that
Renfield has done a better job of
capturing the Mortal Kombat aesthetic
than any of the franchise's official
movies
Nicholas Cage's interpretation of
Dracula is one for the history books and
in some ways a perfect bookend to his
1988 freakout classic Vampire's Kiss but
for all its zaniness and Camp there is
another layer of the character that the
actor captures as well the charm and
Allure that Dracula has over women is
not lost on cage seduction has always
been a part of vampire stories and the
way cage incorporates Dracula's sex
appeal is one of the most book accurate
elements of Renfield vampire movies
invite the realm of fantasy or magic
near the end of the film Dracula comes
face to face with
the Lobo mount
La Francesca Lobo
first confrontation Bella Francesca is
Intoxicated by Dracula's seductive
nature Dracula uses these powers to his
Advantage seducing Bella Francesca and
winning her affections just long enough
to let him take over the Lobo Clan
in the film's final shot Renfield once
again pays direct homage to 1931's
Dracula before the credits begin there
is one final Stinger that Dracula fans
will definitely recognize after the
action has wrapped up the movie cuts to
a title card the title Renfield appears
in the same font used in the original
film the title logo also pays homage to
the colorized posters featuring a yellow
typeface with red highlights the
Striking image is an effective way to
bring the tongue-in-cheek Love Letter to
Dracula that is Renfield to a close the
end credits continue his throwback in a
stylish manner that keeps Renfield
humble by acknowledging the Legacy from
which it was born
[Music]
foreign